[Music]
thank you
it's a mark thank you oh my God he
tripped me
I recently directed the film cocaine
bear
and
without visual effects this is what the
bear would look like
thank you
it's terrifying
stop it no director wants to deal with
this okay what are you doing stop it
stop put your paw down
why are you are you trying to score
right now you need to wait till the
after party like everybody else
the coke is not real it's visual effects
right it's all that why are you dragging
Sigourney Weaver into this do not drag
Legend she doesn't no what the navi are
not real it's visual effects avatars
visual effects
is this All Quiet on the Western Front
okay that's visual effects it was a real
war but real visual effects
Batman flying around is not real
Tom Cruise flying around Israel
but also
visual effects
wakanda
wakanda is totally real
effects can enhance any sorry in my
voice visual effects can enhance any
story and our incredible tool for
filmmakers like me and without visual
effects cocaine bear would have been
some actor in a bear suit probably on
cocaine
huh here are the nominees for
achievement in visual effects
get out
All Quiet on the Western Front Frank
petzl Victor Miller makus Frank and
Camille Jafar
Avatar the way of water Joe the Terry
Richard bainham Eric Sanden and Daniel
Barrett
the Batman Dan lemon Russell Earl Anders
langlins and Dominic Tui
black panther wakanda forever Jeffrey
Bauman Craig hammock R Christopher white
and Dan sudik
top gun Maverick Ryan Ted Hope Seth hill
Brian litson and Scott R Fisher
and the Oscar goes to
Avatar the way of water Joe the Terry
Richard Eric and then Daniel bear
for all the navi and Recons the
designers Incorporated elements of the
actors into the character's designs to
help translate their performances and
bring them to life
where where that affects uh they're
they're two thousand strong in some ways
uh leaner with the production team Joe
leading the artist an army of artists
and the amazingly talented supervisor
that we have are the effects Style on
the shoulder of of our actors our
performances are everything
and yeah we need to thank our families
[Music]